bien aquí tenemos esta cámara digital la
voy a desmontar para mostrarles cómo
funciona aquí tenemos las baterías y por
aquí está el botón de encendido y ya que
tenemos la cámara encendida tomaremos
algunas fotografías y pueden ver que la
pantalla lcd permite ver lo que está
sucediendo y nos muestra las fotografías
la pantalla de lcd es retro iluminada
con un led ahora bien es importante
mencionar que el stm se refiere a
pantalla de cristal líquido y leer a
diodo emisor de luz bien continuemos así
que manos a la obra es hora de
desmontarla y quitaremos todos los
tornillos que mantienen a las dos
mitades de la cámara juntas y con esto
retiraremos la parte de arriba que
probablemente está hecha con abs y este
es el bisel galvanizado que rodea al
lente de la cámara y todo está
atornillado en su lugar y probablemente
este bisel también este hecho de abs
chapado
ahora vamos a observar cómo se ven y de
qué está hecho el pestillo tenemos una
placa de acero cromado conectada con un
resorte que hace circular la
electricidad desde la parte inferior
detrás de las baterías hasta la placa
por aquí es donde se encuentra la
conexión positiva de la placa en la
parte inferior y la conexión negativa
está en la parte superior ahora bien si
quitamos el perno podremos quitar la
tapa y bueno por acá tenemos la placa
metálica que ahora se puede mover de
atrás hacia adelante y de hecho puedes
ver el movimiento les recuerdo que esto
es acero cromado y podemos ver que tiene
cuatro pequeñas conexiones ahora vamos a
remover también esta pieza de atrás la
cual está simplemente insertada y creo
que probablemente está estampada por
medio de calor estampar por medio de
calor es una manera de sujetar las
piezas de metal a muy bajo costo pueden
ver estos cuatro puntos y también fueron
sujetados aplicando calor observa que es
magnético entonces podemos decir que es
acero cromado
ahora vamos a remover los tornillos que
sujetan el bisel de plástico que rodea
la cámara y une los dos lados y pueden
ver que esta es una pieza de plástico
moldeada por inyección creo que el
material podría ser a bs pero hasta
ahorita no tiene una designación de
plástico en ella así que no es 100%
seguro podría ser también polipropileno
o tal vez poliestireno aquí tenemos el
botón de encendido y apagado y el botón
del disparador cuando son presionados
accionan los interruptores en la
membrana que están montados en la placa
de circuito impreso o en la parte de la
placa del circuito impreso en donde se
conectan ahora vamos a quitar los
tornillos que sostienen la placa en su
lugar
bien tratamos de retirar todos los
tornillos que sostenían la montura del
tripié pero uno de ellos está desgastado
así que lo dejaremos en su lugar vamos a
retirar la parte de atrás y veremos las
dos cubiertas de los botones son de
modelo por inyección de plástico y
después son pintadas y sujetados
aplicándoles calor así que pueden ver el
color plateado y bueno para sujetar por
calor
simplemente se derrite un pequeño pivote
de plástico para sujetar la pieza con
otra parte de la cubierta y como les
decía es una manera de sujetar las
piezas a muy bajo costo sirve para
mantenerlos en su lugar sobre los
interruptores en la membrana bien y aquí
puedes ver en qué lugares van estos son
los botones de encendido y apagado y
este es el botón selector el cual te
permite desplazarte por las imágenes
después tenemos el botón del menú y de
reproducir ahora por acá tenemos paso a
paso lo que sucede cuando tomas una
fotografía
lo primero que sucede es que el lente de
aquí capta un poco de luz así que vamos
a verlo con calma la luz del sol le pega
después la luz se refleja en el llega
hasta el lente y después se concentra en
nuestro sensor de imagen y cuando hace
eso pasa a través de estos dos filtros
en este punto los fotones son los que
transmiten la información es simplemente
la luz reflejada que transmite
información hasta nuestro sensor de
imagen aquí tenemos un filtro infrarrojo
que básicamente ayuda a mantener la luz
infrarroja fuera ya que puede afectar la
imagen tenemos también un filtro de
color de bayer o mosaico de bayer que se
encuentran en la parte superior del
sensor de imagen el cual básicamente
divide el sensor en un mosaico de rojo
verde y azul aquí hay dos veces más
verde que rojo y azul porque nuestros
ojos son más sensibles a algunos colores
que otros así que el mosaico de bayer
nos permite recopilar información del
color del sensor de imagen también es
importante mencionar que hay dos tipos
de sensores de imagen ccd o dispositivo
de carga acoplada y los cimos o
semiconductores complementarios
y lo metálico los ccd tienden a tener
menos ruido que los sismos por lo cual
llegan a ser un poco más caros y sus
componentes para realizar el
procesamiento analógico no son montados
en una placa sino fuera de ella ahora lo
hicimos tienen componentes como algunos
transitores para realizar el
procesamiento analógico que van montados
en una placa por lo que los sismos son
un poco menos costosos también tienden a
consumir menos energía y tienden a tener
más ruido por lo que la calidad de
imagen suele ser menor pero puede haber
excepciones si tienes un sí más costoso
y un ccd económico esto que dije no
aplica sólo hablo en general la luz
llega al sensor de imagen y es
convertida en señales eléctricas
analógicas estas señales eléctricas son
enviadas a un convertidor de analógico a
digital y después las señales digitales
pueden ser representadas como unos y
ceros y son enviadas al procesador
digital de imagen el procesador digital
de imagen en esta cámara en particular
se encuentra debajo
la pantalla cubierto por una mancha
negra que realmente es una resina epoxi
esta es una manera económica de proteger
el procesador bien el procesador se
encarga de decodificar el mosaico lo que
quiere decir que toma la información que
fue creada por el filtro de color y
también los píxeles individuales y la
reparte proporcionalmente para crear una
imagen más nítida y utilizó un software
que hace un algoritmo para ello por
ejemplo aquí pueden ver que hay un
pequeño cabello que está representado
ahí en un gran acercamiento a la imagen
de vídeo
y bueno también puede utilizarse para
convertir a jpg y otras cosas ahora qué
te parece si volteamos la cámara y vemos
el buffer de memoria que se encuentra
del otro lado pueden ver que está allí
es el chip grande y el buffer de memoria
recibe las imágenes y las almacena antes
de que se envíen al controlador de la
tarjeta de memoria o cerrojo octal que
básicamente funcionan como un
controlador de tráfico de datos que van
a la memoria flash la memoria flash es
este chip de aquí y en la memoria flash
es en donde se almacena toda la
información en esta cámara en particular
en la mayoría de las cámaras la memoria
flash se puede desmontar pero en esta ya
viene incorporada probablemente porque
es más económico que comprar un conector
la pantalla lcd la pueden ver justo aquí
y después tenemos una conexión usb que
por supuesto pueden tomar el cable y
conectarlo a la computadora e imprimir
sus imágenes u otra manera de obtener
sus imágenes finales
veamos algunos otros componentes este
por aquí es un altavoz piezoeléctrico
que conduce un sonido de alta frecuencia
cuando presionas los botones lo cual es
una respuesta auditiva para hacerte
saber que el botón ha sido presionado
exitosamente la placa está hecha por el
material laminar si observamos los demás
componentes en la placa aquí tenemos un
led y tenemos también otro por aquí y
ambos leds indican cuando la cámara está
encendida y además cuando una fotografía
ha sido tomada ahora veamos en este lado
de la placa hay un pequeño componente
plateado es un temporizador de 4 el
temporizador permite sincronizar todas
las funciones en la placa y es utilizado
por el microprocesador ahora por acá
pueden ver las resistencias y los
capacitores las resistencias usualmente
son señaladas por una red mientras que
los capacitores son señalados con unace
y pueden usarse juntas para filtrar el
ruido también para influir en algunos
tiempos de sincronización de las
funciones
son utilizados para proteger varios
circuitos en la placa y algunos
componentes ahora estos componentes de
aquí son componentes de energía éstos
toman la energía de la batería y la
hacen más útil para la cámara y también
pueden ver las pistas aquí toda la parte
superior de la placa está cubierta de
cobre y posteriormente se retira el
cobre en las partes donde no se
necesitan conexiones así que las
conexiones están hechas con el cobre que
queda y de esa manera tienes conexión
entre todos los componentes que están en
la placa ahora vamos a abrir la pantalla
para ver qué hay adentro dentro de la
pantalla vamos a ver que hay un led y
una resistencia que protege al led y una
pieza de plástico transparente y después
un reflector blanco en la parte de atrás
y después está seguido de un difusor
blanco que es una pieza delgada de
plástico y la parte brillante de la
pantalla todas estas piezas son
diseñadas para equilibrar la luz
alrededor de la pantalla y ayudan a
emitirla de manera uniforme ya que sólo
hay un punto de luz creado por el led
para asegurarse que las imágenes estén
iluminadas apropiadamente por la parte
posterior y la pantalla lcd se encuentra
hasta arriba es un sándwich entre dos
piezas de vidrio y estas piezas de
vidrio contienen dentro el cristal
líquido que lo puedes distinguir por el
color ahumado que seguramente puedes ver
a través de estas dos piezas de vidrio
al menos se puede ver un poco y éstas se
encienden o mejor dicho toman diferentes
colores y son iluminadas por el led
detrás de ellas para mostrar la imagen
cuando tomas una fotografía o cuando
estás viendo tus imágenes bueno para
finalizar quiero agradecer a todos los
que me dieron una crítica constructiva
en el vídeo anterior siempre estamos
buscando formas de mejorar